when it comes to politicians in lying
there are politician lies and there are
lies told by politicians now a
politician lie would be we've had the
best job creation in history over the
last four years and then you say well
you know measured in this way it's kind
of true if you account for fact or why
but if you don't include Y and use Z and
look at the unemployment rate versus
labor participation
it's a politician lie right it could be
true maybe not really depends how you're
measuring it then there are just
flat-out lies me saying I'm a woman
that's a lie that is a demonstrable lie
now that I'm going to invite people to
necessarily check in the ways you might
imagine but that is just a demonstrable
lie right Donald Trump told demonstrable
and provable lies during this debate I
want to get to the first one of these
and this is well just play it for you
and then we'll discuss in fact Donald
was one of the people who rooted for the
housing crisis he said back in 2006 gee
I hope it does collapse cos and I can go
in and buy some and make some money well
it did collapse that's called business
by nine million people nine million
people lost their jobs
okay not exactly a lie I will actually
get to the lies next but a statement
that is damning in terms of Trump's
understanding of what business's Trump's
interruption that business at its core
is taking advantage of the financial
misery of individuals at the hand of the
bank at the hands of the banking and
mortgage industry as a way to make money
if that is business for Trump that is
absolutely shameful and then I believe
that Donald Trump was just basically on
tilt where he said the following when
called out by Hillary Clinton about his
prior claims regarding climate change
and China listen to this take clean
energy some country is going to be the
clean energy superpower of the 21st
century
Donald thinks that climate change is a
hoax perpetrated by the Chinese I think
it's real I did not I do not say that I
I do not see that we grip this instantly
fact-checked
we will put up a couple of the tweets
that Donald Trump has sent out about
this exact issue Trump saying I didn't
say it but he did if you're watching
with us you can now see the first tweet
the concept of global warming was
created by and for the Chinese in order
to make us manufacturing non-competitive
and another tweet from Donald Trump on
this exact same issue where he said
snowing in Texas and Louisiana
record-setting freezing temperatures
throughout the country and beyond
global warming is an expensive hoax he's
tweeted over a hundred times about
global warming according to an archive
of Trump's tweets going back to 2009
almost all of the global warming or
climate change related tweets are ones
where he says that it is a hoax and
indeed he said that it was something
China was involved in Hillary Clinton
did an excellent job at baiting Donald
Trump and notorious Republican pollster
and sort of message craft or Frank Luntz
put out an interesting tweet on this
I'll show that to you where he said
Hillary Clinton has learned how to bait
Trump he doesn't know how not to take it
her attacks work his defenses won't
so Trump caught lying in absolutely
shameful and embarrassing fashion during
the debate this was one of the areas
where Hillary Clinton excelled it is no
longer necessary to choose between price
and quality to get an amazing and
affordable shave dollarshaveclub.com is
the answer to prove how amazing their
shave really is right now they are going
to give you your first month free to
join the club dollarshaveclub.com
delivers great razors right to my door
for a third of the price of what the
greedy razor corporations are charging
if you know me you know I can't stand
dealing with lines and crowded stores
and I have no reason to deal with that
nor those locked up razors that you need
an employee's permission to unlock at
your local store just go to
dollarshaveclub.com
and pick a razor that works for you from
lineup of amazing blades that's all
there is to it I've been pairing the
executive blade with their doctor
carvers shave butter the blade glides
for a super smooth shave and with Dollar
Shave Club you can look smell and shave
like a million bucks without paying for
it here's your chance to see why over
three million members like me love
Dollar Shave Club Dollar Shave Club is
so confident in the quality of all their
products now you can get your first
month of the club for free just pay
shipping after that just a few bucks a
month no long-term commitment contracts
or hidden fees there is no reason not to
do it get yours at dollarshaveclub.com
slash Pakman dollarshaveclub.com slash
PA que ma n